stationnée devant la résidence et puis
laisser ses lumières ouverte le soir par
exemple juste pour intimider pour pour
montrer on surveille l'eau puis on est
là
donc moi ce moment alors immédiatement
appelé la police n'a pas laissé était au
courant et c'est là qu'ils ont instauré
la protection policière pour pour me
protéger donc des policiers au niveau
plus d'arômes c'est la sûreté du québec
mais où je demeurais passé dix-huit fois
devant ma maison sur 24 heures donc ils
restèrent moyenne 5 à 10 minutes donc
remplissait son rapport souvent m
envoyer la main ça a été assez lot de
subir cette pression lors à cette époque
donc c'était c'était une situation qui
tu es personne n'a envie de vivre sur
leurs une intimidation et de cette façon
là on se sent plus en sécurité dans sa
propre maison
donc c'est une période de ma vie leur
qui est assez noir
vous avez des jeunes ados à ce moment
oui à l'époque l'om et deux garçons
avaient 13 15 heures ça fait deux ans et
demi donc
de beaux grands garçons que j'adore mais
eux ce qu'ils ont et ceux qui la façon
qu'ils ont vécue parce qu'on en a parlé
aux joueurs en ai parlé à cette époque
là c'est peut-être pas de crainte pour
eux nécessairement mais c'était de
partir le matin en autobus allaient à
l'école de revenir le soir puis que je
sois plus là où peu importe le
inconsciente atteindre ou peut-être même
or donc été hissé pour des adolescents
c'est pas le fond une loterie mais il
avait tout un mécanisme de protection
pour eux aussi le à l'école de la
direction était au courant des
intervenants étaient au courant donc
chapeau où l'on à l'école d'avoir bien
su protéger mes enfants aussi puis elle
un protocole qui étaient implantés que
s'il arrive quoi que ce soit mais il y
avait des directives claires le pour
hull il y avait une question de votre
rapport avec avec les plus jeunes aussi
de l'exemple que vous vouliez donner
oui ben c'est sûr je suis quand même
beaucoup impliqué au niveau et les
écoles bon sur les conseils
d'établissement tout ça et puis on
enseigne aux élèves dans les écoles
primaires secondaires et l'importance de
dénoncer l'intimidation et puis en tant
qu'adulte
c'est notre devoir de montrer l'exemple
puis de dire regardez ont même quand on
est adulte on paye de victimes
d'intimidation mais faut le dénoncer
il faut le dénoncer donc c'est un
message aussi qu'on envoie à nos
générations futures de l'importance si
on veut que l'on croit quand tout le
monde croit en la justice sociale bien
un moment donné il faut le dénoncer